my wife is out getting laid right now
and I never thought I'd be here but yet
I am
you know every day I lose a little faith
in society a little bit
this weekend my wife 38 female and our
daughter 13 female went to visit her mom
I couldn't go because I couldn't get
time off work and we decided it would
just be a girls weekend for them I'm a
firefighter in a large southern city and
I'm on a call and gearing up when our
dispatcher calls in to tell me there is
some emergency I'm not really needed on
the work call so I got my cell phone and
found a bunch of texts from my kid and a
couple from a number I don't have in my
phone in the course of about 11 text
messages I learned that my daughter has
gone ice skating and fallen and broken
her wrist she's in the emergency room
but could not get treatment because no
one can find my wife the number I don't
know belongs to a friend of my wife's
who's gone to the emergency room to sit
with my kid she was The Chaperone for
the girls who's gone skating so I called
this friend and after a lot of hemming
and hawing she admits that wifey has
gone to dinner with some random guy well
we always leave our location shared with
the family because of my job and sure
enough I pull up the address and Google
it and it's an effing Hotel this was 10
p.m and it's almost four hours later she
hasn't answered my text but she finally
did call her kid I have permission and
insurance information and she got a cast
and a referral to see an orthopedist
when she gets home the friend took her
daughter back to her grandmother's and
texted me she said I'm so sorry that you
had to find out this way about a guy's
name apparently it's been going on every
time she's gone home that I haven't gone
meanwhile I've worked countless hours of
overtime to pay off our house take us on
nice vacations and send her daughter to
the most expensive private school in our
city I'm a fool
um okay so I rarely ever recommend
divorce
but I'll tell you why it's actually
important that men divorce or at least
separate from these women
I'm assuming there's no abuse cheating
on his side
you you teach your daughter there's no
consequences for this type of
you know kids aren't stupid and a lot of
times they spend more time with the
woman than you do
so by accepting this Behavior you're
basically teaching your daughter that
this shit's okay
um and what kind of you know what kind
of mother is she If instead of you know
catering to her daughter she's effing
some guy in a hotel
um and it's really it you know I I some
guys probably will would stick it out
for the kids for a couple years you know
I think that's to the discretion of the
guy I mean he knows the daughter better
but uh this is sad and I've heard this
story a lot where women will go home and
they'll cheat at their parents house and
their whole family knows the whole thing
yeah so I would say make sure there's a
really there's there's got to be at
least a separation I know I know they're
gonna call me a hypocrite because Pearl
doesn't believe in divorce well the men
used to separate from these women they'd
like throw them in like a dungeon or
salt okay not a dungeon but they would
you know they'd like throw her in
another house or like an apartment and
say you gotta work now lady and I would
get evidence of everything I would get
evidence of everything you're talking
about in case you have to go to court
because a lot of these chicks when they
you know they're looking for the next
best option they don't usually cheat to
stay they usually cheat to leave so um I
would hire an attorney soon as you can
and protect yourself that's what I would
do
um
but
yeah guys you know um this is just my
thoughts on on different situations and
I and I think there's a whole side of
divorce that is not spoken about and I
think for about 50 years we've been
hearing the woman's point of view and
okay
women have gone through some stuff not
much these days but some stuff and we've
heard you but I think at some point we
got to listen to the men and what the
men have to say and really guys the
quality of wives on the market is subpar
it is bad I I don't I think I know maybe
five traditional women that actually
obey their husbands and when the quality
of the wife on the market this is the
Christian conservative women means
having a nanny work a hundred hours a
week to raise your kids for you and you
accuse your husband of abuse 24 7. um I
I think we're in we're in tough times so
let me know what you guys think in the
comments also get yourself a woman
should have vote t-shirt today like the
video on your way out subscribe to the
channel and I'll talk to you next time